it's good to see you ping yeah so I
guess the first question is what's it
like to be a Stanford
I spend actually a fair bit of time on
campus here you know we're headquartered
very nearby just across Page Mill Road
right at the corner of Page Mill and El
Camino and we get a lot of opportunities
to come and speak on campus and to
engage with students and we've got a
very successful internship program there
recruits from here and I make it a point
to donate a little bit extra money in
time to my alma mater as a result of my
engagement down here so it's good for
everybody hopefully the audience will
take it easy on you so you know I'm sure
a lot of folks have read about you know
the founding of Clara and how it got
started but I'd love to hear from your
perspective and you know not the
bloggers or what how do you how would
you describe the early days you
pre-funding pre-everything yeah you bet
so for those of you don't know what
Clara does as we commercialize some
software that was originally invented at
Google and the software is called Hadoop
and as for working with lots of data big
data in ways that you never could before
in the early part of 2008 I had sold my
previous company to Oracle and and I did
two years of lockup at Oracle after that
acquisition it was a good experience but
but when the two years ended I left I
was looking for the next thing to do I
began looking around for interesting
opportunities in the industry and I came
across had two and I'd heard about it
before but not paid much attention when
I dove in with some of the big users of
the software Facebook and Yahoo and
others and understood what they were
doing I got super excited and I want to
start a company around it so I did what
you do right I walked around and talked
to everybody I knew and in the process
of doing that I found three other guys
who had decided that there was an
opportunity to create a company around
Hadoop and all four of us had an idea of
what that company is going to go do so
you know sort of early summer 2008 there
are four different people looking to
create a company on technology no one's
ever heard of in pursuit of a zero
dollar market right did not sound right
yeah recipe for success right two of the
people who were looking at doing that
we're actually being at the time
incubated at XL ping had found these
guys at Facebook and a yahoo
respectively
the four of us just by networking around
and looking for others working on this
found one another we spent really the
summer trying to decide if we could
collapse four cap tables into a single
cap table and create one company and we
successfully did that and let me say had
we not I think would have been a
disaster right it would have been a lack
of focus and it would have been very
distracting for all of us by the end of
the summer we all believed that we could
work together we spent a little bit of
time in the very early fall putting
together a strategy and thinking about
how we'd raise money Excel had incubated
Jeff and amor as I said in order to
encourage them to go and do something
interesting was interested in funding it
and ping was the partner that had driven
that that's how I got introduced to him
I knew it I knew Excel quite well but
given that we had the four people
thinking about starting a company and
the one investor in the valley who is
interested in doing something that they
do I figured let's just take all this
stuff off the market right so we wound
up raising our Series A round from accel
ping joined the board with the funding
in October 2008 just you know one side
story I don't know well how well you
guys remember those were dark days right
like a week later lame and declared
bankruptcy right that's terrible for all
of us in our personal portfolios from
cutter a selfish position it was
actually quite a good thing
what happened was we closed the funding
round the money hit the bank account
Wall Street imploded the steel door
slammed down on page Mill Road I mean if
you knew how to turn lead into gold
you could not raise venture capital for
that right it was just impossible and
that meant we just had to feel to
ourselves for like a year nobody could
enter the market that gave us a
playground basically to go do the stuff
we wanted to do and engage with
customers it was it was a very
interesting time so Mike when you you
know the summer of 2008 but what was it
about Hadoop that kind of and maybe tell
a little folks here exactly you know go
a little more detail in a dupe and what
was going on in the valley at the time
and how'd you why'd you
think there was actually an opportunity
to turn you know this open-source
project into you know what the company
that it is today so a very brief
technical diversion I want to explain
kind of how this software works I'm an
old guard relational database guy I've
built and sold relational database
products and I built it as old companies
that built and sold relational database
products for my entire career so I was
very deeply steeped in how those systems
worked and what they were good at what
they were not so good at back in the day
if you wanted to manage data what you
did was you called up Sun Microsystems
and you had them ship you the very
biggest box they had right and you wrote
him a check for that and if you had a
little bit of money left over you would
call up Oracle and you would get some
database software to run on that one big
computer right and that was your data
temple that's where everything went big
centralized servers were how we built
systems back then then you could connect
to that from lots of places but all your
data had to be in that one big box and
the way we built systems assumed one big
box right it was just a single computer
that stuff ran on when Google wanted to
index the entire internet it turned out
there was no box big enough right you
couldn't buy a single computer that
would fit the entire web even in 2000
right Google didn't realize what we knew
in the data base industry and that was
that it was impossible to build massive
scale out data management infrastructure
so they just went ahead and did it and
you passed Stanford guys just pissed me
off
Google invented a scale out platform
that would do that and the way that they
did it was instead of one big Sun
Microsystems box a whole bunch of little
computers that were ganged together all
of them have local discs all of them
have local processing you get a bunch of
data and you bust it into pieces and
just peanut butter spread it around all
those servers right oh you know what
you're gonna lose some of those servers
because they're cheap and unreliable so
just store multiple copies and let the
software account for those failures
right so you can store the data really
cheaply not just store it all those
computers have a lot of processors on
them so you've got a bunch of compute
power distributed among all your data so
if you want to ask a question of a whole
bunch of data you send that question out
to all those computers and they all look
at the
little piece of data reason about it and
produce an answer and that's honestly
you guys it's a miracle right you can
run you can run a query on a hundred
terabytes of data and get an answer back
in minutes and you can buy ten times
more computers and you can ask that same
question of a petabyte of data and you
get an answer back in the same number of
minutes this is unheard of this had
never happened before in the industry so
that platform was really transformative
and Google was able to use it to index
the web to observe user behavior right
they want to continually improve their
search results so they watch the links
you click on and automatically adjust
the way they return results to others
running similar searches that processing
power was really transformative for them
I had left Oracle I was looking for
something new to work on I recognized
that this was just a vastly different
architecture than we've been building
for decades and simultaneously two
things had happened in the industry one
is you could buy cheap computers from a
lot of enters so this commodity hardware
architecture totally had happened right
the way we build data centers now is not
one big computer it's just racks and
racks and racks of commodity boxes but
another important trend happened and
that was all of you guys started
carrying around cell phones all of you
guys started using Twitter and Facebook
and the volume of data basically machine
generated data you know telemetry from
where you are the transponder in your
car that talks to toll booths and Road
sensors data was being generated at
Machine scale and that was new so three
things happened really simultaneously
interesting new compute and storage
platform invented by Google that ran on
newly cheaply available commodity
hardware that you can get from a lot of
vendors at a time when data volume data
variety data velocity were all exploding
right that three Plex of things really
created the perfect wave Jeff and Armour
and I and Christophe the four of us who
were looking at we all saw all of those
trends at the same time we all
recognized that they were going to be a
big deal not for computer
we're internet they've been successful
there right but for banks and insurance
companies and hospitals the conviction
that big data would happen broadly was
what really brought us together and what
convinced us that there was a big
opportunity to commercialize this
software and I would say you know touch
book we were the first I think we were
far-seeing I think we've executed pretty
well but the market very deeply believes
this now there's lots of investment lots
of activity the opportunity has grown
just tremendously in the last several
years but maybe one thing that just a
historical perspective Hadoop ended up
becoming an open source project at Yahoo
woodcutting indeed and and what was that
how did that open source community
evolve around around around Hadoop so I
presume you guys know the meme but the
idea on open source software is a bunch
of volunteers and companies around the
world collaborate by sharing source code
and writing source code together to make
the software happen Google had invented
this idea and written some research
papers on it and there was an engineer
in the valley a guy named Doug cutting
who read the first Google paper in 2004
and he happened to be working just in
the way one does on a project of his own
to index the entire Internet right and
he recognized he was not going to be
able to do that with conventional
systems he read this Google paper he got
excited right he thought I can use these
techniques in my project so Doug and one
other guy a guy named Mike caffarelli
who's faculty on the East Coast now for
I'm gonna blank and I don't want to get
it wrong Doug and Mike created the
Hadoop project to turn Google magic into
basically open source the rest of the
consumer Internet companies recognize
that Google had an unfair advantage in
search right they were able to do stuff
that no one else could do and so Yahoo
in particular decided that it had an
opportunity to disrupt Google and to end
Google's hegemony and search you can
argue about whether or not Google Yahoo
was successful in doing that
right but Google embraced this open
source project staffed it up Facebook
piled on and hired a bunch of engineers
that began contributing to the project
and this Hadoop open source software
emerged from the
internet as a collaborative effort
driven really by the competitive dynamic
with Google against the rest of the
industry the decision to make that
source software open source that was
Doug cuttings ethical and strategic
commitment he believes and open source
by the way I said why I mean a bunch of
us that clutter I have pretty deep open
source roots this platform would never
have gotten this good it would never
have advanced this quickly if it had
been owned by one company if we hadn't
been able to bring together the genius
of the entire planet and then by the way
if it hadn't been so easy to get and so
easy to adapt to specific years so the
open source decision was huge in
establishing and advancing had to beyond
anything else in the market and that
drive the decision to bring dog into
klaris within months of the founding of
the yeah well honestly so Jeff and Chris
Oppenheimer and I won each from Facebook
Oracle Yahoo and google came together to
form the company in the very beginning
we were from the very beginning deeply
interested in having Doug join the
business for all the obvious reasons I
will say Doug is a very good friend and
I like and respect him and I think he
feels the same way about me and I'll go
ahead and speak for him now I will tell
you they're probably in late 2008 he's
probably thinking I don't know about
these cloud era guy is there might be a
lot of companies that are
commercializing a doob I'm not sure who
these guys alright feel a little bit
careful right I might have to go be
Linna store vaults and and be like
Switzerland in the Hadoop ecosystem so
we didn't manage to close him in the
very beginning I think he was really
encouraged by Clara's demonstrated
commitment to open source and our
investment and creating software that we
came awake as part of the community he
got to know us generally and he and I in
particular began to build a relationship
and by August of 2009 we convinced him
that he belong to the business at that
point he joined I will say that Doug
lives in st. Helena California he's got
a beautiful home and his family lived
there he grew up in that town and he's
raising his kids in that town and he's
got a little ten bite
ten shed out back of his house where he
makes open-source magic happen
and he mostly just lives and works up
there so once a month beginning in
January I would drive up and I would
have lunch or dinner with Doc to try to
recruit the Clara and you know I was
just like not making progress and I
finally decided up I clearly need to
uplevel this conversation so the next
time I went up a beginning like in about
June I started bringing my wife Teresa
and inviting Doug's wife Ann to join us
and I just started recruiting the family
it's an open-source project it's a
family thing yeah I will say Doug
like me I'm sorry here's here's what I
would say this and Cockrell cutting
would be married to the inventor of
fundamental technology that changed the
world and Doug would be pumping gas the
two of them hooked up and and made the
right decision and Doug joined clutter
that's a great story
so just you mentioned a word Big Data
yeah earlier I know when cloud era was
found in 2008 big data was not a word
yeah you guys I didn't know yeah no no
now it's on every billboard it's you
know it's it's hip to say big data what
I mean cloud era gets a lot of credit
for kind of causing the this this wave
of big data what does big data mean you
actually if you had to boil it down I'm
gonna give you sort of the broadly
accepted view and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually tell you what I think so
it's possible your heads on lots of data
it's possible your hands on lots of
kinds of data and and it's possible for
you to get your hands on a firehose of
data these days right any one of those
can happen to you right you can get a
transactional data and tweets and
weather models and that complexity is
just my goodness it's a bunch of
different stuff and you can get
literally petabytes easily it's hard not
to get terabytes these days right that
used to be a scary number right now so
absolutely 100 terabytes hardly anything
right and the volume the velocity rather
of which it arrives can be overwhelming
any one of those by themselves could
feel like big data to you if you've got
two or more of those problems it can be
absolutely over
so volume variety velocity those are the
memes that the industry is generally
embraced my point of view is if if
there's data you want to work with and
it doesn't fit where you want to put it
it's big data and that might be because
it's complicated and you've got lots of
different kinds it might be because you
want to ask way more complicated
questions of that data than were
previously possible so there's a there's
a very common until recently research
technique now widely used in the
industry called machine learning and
actually some of that work has been done
here at Stanford I would say probably
better work had been done at Berkeley
machine learning requires good systems
for scaling out very broadly and machine
learning is an unbelievably powerful
technique for deducing facts from data
that aren't obvious using other
techniques you can let the data tell you
what it's about on what's happening and
machine learning really really likes had
two it really likes these scale and
architectures so if you wonder that kind
of analysis if you want to store that
variety if you want to land a petabyte
somewhere and you can't afford to spend
$40,000 a terabyte to do it turns out
this platform is pretty good and big
data big data is that general so you've
talked about how the internet data
centers have used to do web blogs and
clickstream analysis can you give some
examples of a Hadoop now that clutter
has got hundreds of customers is the
leader in Hadoop and big data tell us
how it's been used outside of the
internet data centers and what are some
examples of people yorking yeah give you
guys a few examples that I particularly
like let me say that you know I told you
before I'm a I'm a database guy right
and I've been working in the relational
database industry for for about two and
a half decades before we started cloud
era and you know over that time I made a
very good living and and we had some
really successful companies but you guys
is kind of boring really I mean you know
tighten the screws speed it up 3% a year
or a recent price 5% a year
worked out okay but nobody ever felt
like a man relational databases this is
what I was born to do Larry Ellison
thinks that don't work no he was born to
do many things relational databases were
merely a means to sum which is a means
to sailing right there I love you
brother
yes so we make a very good living at
Cloudera helping companies run workloads
I'll describe some of those workloads in
a minute
we saw the banks we saw two insurance
companies we sell the hospital's right
but it is my deep conviction that as a
society we're going to attack really
important problems in the next decade
right we got to figure out how to
produce and distribute clean water to
people in a warming world and we're
going to figure out ways to do that by
looking at data in new ways seven
billion people on the planet today
forecast to be nine billion people in
2050 that's 2 million new bodies with no
available planet to find new farmland on
we have to figure out a way to produce
food more efficiently and we're gonna do
that with data meaningful cancers will
become manageable chronic diseases in
our lifetime will no longer be a death
sentence but will be diseases that like
aids in rich company in countries now
you can actually manage and live with
for long periods of time and we're gonna
do that by understanding the disease by
using data to understand his progress
better than ever before data really is
gonna matter to us as a society in ways
that it has before IT is gonna be a
social good I believe this deeply we
actually see this happening in our in
our install base so while nobody woke up
feeling that way about relational sin
systems look I know we're not gonna cure
cancer clutter we're not gonna feed 2
million people but we're gonna make
software that lets the planet attack
those problems in new ways I gave you
some concrete examples of use cases we
see some fairly pedestrian some a little
more inspirational if you're a credit
card provider you care about fraud there
are bad
all the time stealing credit cards use
them on the web trying to get goods and
not get caught that's always been a
problem and those firms have been
looking for ways to detect and prevent
fraud for a long time they've been using
techniques by the way like machine
learning at small scale looking at the
last weeks or months worth of
transactional activity it turns out if
you can feed those models a decade's
worth of data you can see patterns you
can learn behaviors that were invisible
in small amounts of data and it's a glib
example but flip a coin three times you
know nothing about that coin flip a coin
a thousand times you got an idea whether
or not that's a fair coin turns out that
lots of data yields value
disproportionately right smarter
algorithms are good but more data to
train your existing arms even better
right one of our customers a global
credit card basically a global card
processing company had been doing fraud
detection at a small scale for a long
time they brought us in just because
they wanted to store way more data way
more cheaply than ever before land the
last ten years worth of transaction data
and that was for cost reasons
that's all right save a few bucks once
they did that they had all that data on
spinning disk some of their analyst said
you know well let's turn our fraud
models loose on this dales tweak them a
little bit but let's feed them ten years
with the data they discovered the single
largest instance of fraud in the
company's history as a side effect of
saving money on storage so just
aggregating data has allowed them to do
an old thing and in a very powerful new
way one other example I'll hit mental
that you either directly with Moore or
going on the question button so one of
our customers is a company named
explorers medical and they're based in
Cincinnati there is this I'm sorry their
basic Cleveland there has been out of
the cleveland clinic much in the news
these days of course Obamacare and
healthcare.gov and the challenges we
have around that and whatever your
politics are I think you'll agree that
better patient outcomes more reliably at
lower cost that'd be a good thing right
so you get sick you go see your doc you
fill in a form when you get in maybe
wax on your knees takes your blood
pressure talks to you about your
symptoms writes up a scrip sends you
home you feel that scrip
you take the pills that you're
prescribed for a week or two you don't
feel much better right you go back see
your doctor again maybe some more
invasive testing blood draw or other
body samples happen maybe some imaging
maybe call it a specialist look at you
know another doctor give you some more
feedback this time maybe you get some
physical therapy you get a different
prescription you follow that course of
action I'm rooting for you so I'm gonna
say you get better that's right if you
can string that whole story together
you'd have a pretty good picture of your
illness right it's progress over
multiple weeks lots of different data
types in there right lots of
interactions there interstitial delays
the amount of time between your doctor
visits that's significant right now
imagine you can do that for an entire
hospital networks worth of patients
right you could use machine learning to
realize that dr. Jones was getting
disproportionately good outcomes from
women between 35 and 50 years old by
following a specific course of treatment
when they present with similar symptoms
and you can use dr. Jones
outstanding performance to make
recommendations dr. Smith and others to
adapt their treatment that is exactly
what explorance is doing they're looking
at the course of care that aggregate by
basically large aggregations of patients
are getting and the outcomes and thereby
directing healthcare providers to get
better outcomes faster healthcare
actually is going to be a big big area
for exploitation of data in this way so
one of the questions I've always wanted
searching gears live always wanted to
ask you and I never had a chance Suze
how I'm scared of this one why did you
choose the name cloud era has nothing
with to do with Hadoop has nothing to a
data and it's so what was a story behind
that
yeah actually so you guys should also
know that my last company was named
sleepy cat software and what we learned
from sleepy cat was we don't let
engineers name stuff cloud era that name
came about that summer when the four of
us were scheming about
a company at the time cloud computing
was really a hot meme in the industry
right we had no idea what our
go-to-market or product strategy was
going to be right but it was reasonable
to assume that some kind of cloud would
be in there someplace
and the era of the cloud well that's
probably true right so let's go ahead
and do that significantly we could buy
the domain cheap and we actually used a
little subterfuge
again in my life yes we did that in a
clever way we really didn't have any
idea of what the company would do we
chose the name because it sounded like a
good name and because we thought cloud
might make a difference early on a lot
of analysts and a lot of press
misunderstood us they thought oh we're
cloud computing coming turns out we're a
big data company right
in fact our strategy right now only kind
of orthogonal we intersects the cloud
space early on we got a lot of press Inc
because cloud was hot and weena clouded
my name and Airport probably worth
writing about us right it didn't have
one benefit that is you know when you
tie your brand to a meme and energy that
you don't control kind of sucks right so
odd balance I'm satisfied with the
decision to do it my point of view now
is cloud era is just the noise you make
when you're talking about the most
interesting enterprise software company
on the planet right nobody really sobs
leaks what a goofy stupid name Google is
Google right alright well that's that's
a good answer
so I think the you mentioned earlier
that you've been in the relational
database for decades before and now you
talked about the power of Hadoop but
you've also heard you say that the
relational database world serves a
purpose will thrive and live for decades
to come and how do you see the world
evolving the database world haven't been
in it for so long so let me first say
you know we've been doing this for five
years we've been able to watch customers
adopt this technology and evolve the way
that they
use it not just as their UC ball but
over the last five years we've been
driving more capabilities into the
platform started out as this batch mode
scale-out storage magic from Mountain
View right but over time we pushed
security data governance data lineage
the the the right kind of real time
interactivity into the platform so the
platform's got is strictly more capable
and users have gotten strictly more
sophisticated in their use of it so what
well it used to be kind of off on the
periphery right supporting new analytic
workloads but not really overlapping at
all with your data warehouse or your
document management system it was it was
a side system as it's gotten more secure
more real-time as customers have evolved
their use of big data it's kind of moved
into the center of the data center we
actually see it now is sort of an
enterprise data hub right cheap easy
store anything you like full fidelity
for as long as you like it secure so you
don't have to worry about it losing data
you can keep track of that data you got
lineage and governance and it connects
to your data warehouse to your
relational database transaction
processes your document management
system that connectivity not just to
systems by the way but also to users
with the tools that they like makes it a
really attractive place for data to go
first and some of that data doesn't ever
need to move out you're able to get at
it in interactive new ways but the
products that I spent my prior career
buildings are outstanding right online
transaction processing systems grew up
alongside that mission critical business
workload for decades and they are
unbelievably good at it right high-end
enterprise data warehouse bill to cube
spin the cube fly through the cube right
turns out that's pretty hard and those
systems are really good at it what I
think is going to happen is those
high-end domain specific services will
remain as important as they've ever been
but increasingly we'll see data and
other workloads move to this hub because
it's going to be a cheap and easy place
to run that stuff I'm long-term bullish
on relational systems on data warehouse
I think that they will continue to
improve and evolve and they are so
deeply knit in
to the existing enterprise
infrastructure that they'll survive for
a while I do think though that there's
going to be a bit of a reordering and
restructuring of of where data lands
first and how we choose to think about
it I honestly believe today and I
wouldn't have made this forecast back in
2008 I honestly believe that most of the
world's data is going to live in this
platform it's just too obviously a right
architecture not to win in the long term
and just shifting years a little way
from technology into the business at
Cloudera yeah
clutter is an open source company but
the open source business model has
evolved significantly over the last
decade and you've you know been part of
that @cp cad and advisors a lot of other
open source companies how would you
describe choosing the open source model
early on for clutter and what is the
open source model for cloud era or
business model in general and how does
open source play a role in that yeah I
think it's a really important point and
for those of you that are looking at
careers in technology what I'm saying is
it's very different today than it was
even in the late 80s early 90s when I
was first coming out open source has
happened in a really important way in
the early 90s when we started a lustre
out of Berkeley there was no evidence
that you could make money on software
that people gave away just flat out no
evidence right and the idea that that
would be possible was ridiculous over
time a bunch of different strategies for
monetizing the open source have evolved
have been tried out have been improved
some have been discarded the world is
now pretty sophisticated about what are
some of those moms this is just the
context that you know back in back in
the early 19th century businesses
actually had strategies about
electricity right where were you gonna
get it because your own now you know
what you don't have an electricity
strategy right it's just part of the
landscape right
I believe open source software's the
same way it was it was worth thinking
about as a really discrete confusing
complicated thing in the 90s these days
most businesses touch open source in
fundamental ways so if you want to be a
business and then you want to adjust
open
perhaps if you want to write and give
away open-source software how do you get
paid right a bunch of different things
have been tried one is take an
open-source project that's not very good
and make it your own secret internal
project and make it better but don't
share any of your enhancements and
really that's what we did at a lustrum
right we we took the Postgres code on it
Berkeley and made it way better but made
it a proprietary product and insurer
with a sole sold it for cash money just
as if we were Oracle or ingress or other
proprietary database vendors and the
problem with that is you surrender the
contributions of a global community
right your company has to all of a
sudden be better than the rest of the
planet in the aggregate right other
models that have been tried include well
you know the last version is freely
available and open source but the
current version isn't so version lagging
or any pay for the current version and
the old ones are free you can do what
MySQL and and others like JBoss and Red
Hat actually gets gets some credit for
doing this I think Red Hat stretches
more nuances but just be a services
company right yeah the software is free
but if you want support if you want
consulting you come to me you gonna pay
me money the problem with that business
model is that services companies don't
drive real high markets and it doesn't
leave that much money to invest in
making the core product better
so in general those projects tend to
languish Red Hat strategy was actually a
little more newest in that Red Hat
offered a cloud-based management service
Red Hat Network in order to operate
those systems back in the day that was
proprietary software of theirs it just
happened to run on their data center
machinery it didn't get shipped out the
operating systems they ran for their
customers all of that was freely
available but part of their commercial
value was in proprietary software
sleeping at last example and then I'll
talk about what we do a cloud era
sleeping at use a technique called dual
licensing so the idea was we have a good
piece of software but it's only good if
you combine it with software that you
have so if you're building a mail server
webserver you'll want to put our
software in it because then you get good
data management services well you can do
that for free as long as all of your
stuff is also open source and free you
got to give your IP away as well if you
don't like to do that well you can come
and pay us money and we'll sell you a
different license right we called it
dual licensing kind of viral open source
for anybody that wanted to do that and
if you didn't want to give your IP away
you've paid us money another way to
think about it a little more jaundiced
now that I have the experience of doing
it is it's kind of like distributing the
poison and selling the antidote you know
good business you can get it your
relationship with your customer begins
based on a threat and that's not a
really healthy place to start so here's
what I believe in here's what we believe
in cloud era open source innovates
faster spreads faster does great work
faster than any single company can and
embrace of the Hadoop ecosystem giving
away software as part of any because
it's really important for us but we have
to have reasons for companies to buy our
product uniquely and it can't just be
that our people are the most awesome
because it turns out there's way too
many awesome people in the world right
we're not going to be able to control
that precious resource forever we can we
do build proprietary software of our own
that lets our customers get more value
out of their data out of their
infrastructure operated better manage it
better secure it better that's allowed
to be proprietary from us and it creates
differentiation from the pure play
open-source distributions that are
available from some of our competitors
it gives customers a reason to come to
us it gives us a recurring revenue
stream that we can then invest back in
the open source we call that really the
cloud era model it is I think the wave
of the future I think it's a sustainable
way to build an open source business and
the best example I can give by the way
is this is in some sense with IBM does
with Linux right it contributes
substantially to the Linux ecosystem but
it builds and delivers database software
and middleware and other stuff that runs
on top right that allows it to invest
back in that infrastructure anyway it's
certainly been good for us we're you
metric number one in the market but
certainly revenues and customer growth
and that's allowed us to invest more and
faster and drive innovation to a
platform the way I described sorry
I started doing a commercial there no no
it's no I think it's it's a very
distinctive model I think one of the
questions is is that how you think needs
to happen for small open source
derivative software companies to be
standalone and dependent because
historically they've all did the support
services model a lot of distros they
acquired by you name it a big company
and then the project kind of look
obviously peak at the fact that we the
fact that we didn't have a defensible IP
strategy meant that at some point we
couldn't continue to grow we would
attract low cost services competition
from outside the US from cheaper
geographies just from people who
recognized there was an opportunity to
come we would in some sense create our
own competition I think that the only
way to build a long term independent
company is to own proprietary IP I do
think open-source is the way that
platform software is going to happen so
if you're doing enterprise
infrastructure these days and you think
you're going to create a proprietary
software company pure-play I tell you I
think you're wrong
CIOs want open source infrastructure
they insist on it and the ecosystem is
capable of producing it if you want to
build a company that doesn't get
acquired by Oracle but that grows up to
be a company of that scale really your
only choice is to adopt a hybrid
strategy like that and Red Hat is my
favorite example a billion in revenues
plus now write continued growth driven
off of a hybrid strategy that gave them
unique value in operating systems and
delivering open source to their
customers right that is that is our
ambition for sure I think look pure Play
services only open source companies can
and do get to somewhere between 20 and
50 million in revenues and there are
many examples right including our last
company my last company right but for
companies to grow past a hundred and
toward a billion you must have
a more nuanced IP strategy than just
we're going to give all our bytes away
and one of the good things that because
you've taken this models you know
cutters created this really big and huge
market the bad thing is when you create
a huge big and huge market there becomes
a lot of competitors into this space how
you know how do you think about the
dealing with competitors differentiating
and how's that evolved in the last
couple years so you know one thing I'll
say flat out and and this is honestly
true and from the heart we believe from
the beginning creating the company that
we would be building a company worth
billions of dollars right selling into a
market worth tens of billions of dollars
a year and there are zero examples of a
single company in a space that gets to
that scale the only way that you can
make that happen is if there's a rich
ecosystem of companies building and
delivering value in that space
relational databases would never have
become big if it had just been IBM
System are right you need lots and lots
of companies innovating and driving into
the market so while the competitive
pressure create new challenges for us
and force us to up our game if we didn't
have those challenges you would have
wasted your series a investment right
the entrance of players like EMC and
pivotal of IBM into the market much less
the venture back little guys that means
there's an opportunity we have more than
700 companies in our partner program
building apps on top of delivering
integration services for shipping the
hardware that our platform runs on that
ecosystem is focused on winning new
business and driving adoption by
customers that creates huge opportunity
for us right that allows us to sell into
a way bigger market than we could ever
have made happen on our own we just got
a lot more hands banging on the drum
than we ever could have created on our
own um the emergence of real competition
has forced us to up our game and you
know you've been in the boardroom and
very supportive as we've done it
but what five-year-old company is
simultaneously in a knife fight with IBM
sa
and Tarantino right I mean first world
problems guys but problems right I mean
you know we are forced now to operate at
a scale and with a professionalism that
is unusual in the market it's driven by
the scale of the opportunity we wouldn't
have those competitors if they didn't
see the dollar is happening but growing
up that fast has forced us to be very
very disciplined and to be careful about
bringing in new leadership and new
capabilities steadily over the life of
the business right so I want to leave
some time for questions I got a few more
here for Mike but if you guys have
questions raise your hand and we'll work
them in so as you're thinking about your
questions Mike one of the kind of
switching gears a little bit too you
know the entrepreneur entrepreneurship
and yeah starting a company
what kept you up at night in the first
year at Cloudera
and how is it different what keeps you
up at night today Clara so ping makes an
important point here if you are
regularly sleeping through the night as
a founder of a tech company you are
doing it wrong there is always something
that should be scaring the crap out of
you always always always you know in
those very first days what we knew was
we wanted to be a product company we
hadn't yet figured out what the product
was going to be
we'd engaged with a handful of very
valuable clients and we were struggling
to try to abstract their requirements
and figure out what our unique product
strategy could be and in the experience
of servicing those guys and delivering
software that was valuable to them we
were into real operational issues they
were running meaningful jobs on the
platform we had the service we had to
support them and we had to innovate on
the product and figuring out how to
balance that activity to have enough
engineering capacity to make them
successful but then also to make our
product successful
that was a huge stressor in those early
days right now that was the single
biggest challenge
what will our product be honestly I will
tell you there's no question in our
minds now of the scale of the
opportunity we'll never stop being
strategic in thinking about our product
and where
to go but over the course of the next
two years frankly our challenge is going
to be living up to the competitive set
that we've attracted to the market right
I mean I'm out there punching it out for
deals with big enterprise vendors who
for two decades have been selling
seventy seven eight million dollar
annual deals to c-level executives of
the Fortune 1000 they visit each other
at Christmastime in their homes right
the salespeople and the execs of those
and somehow we have to inject ourselves
into those relationships as a bold
little 500 person company based in Palo
Alto and be credible right and growing
up that way requires discipline requires
excellence requires new ways of behavior
that we are learning that we are
adopting as we go and and look I'm
bullish I believe we're gonna do it the
man I'm sweating that one I am sweating
that one any questions well one thing is
everything I've read says that credit
card companies don't pursue fraud it's
easier for them to just let somebody
take a ding on their credit report then
for them to go through the legal process
of pursuing fraud the other thing is
about cloud computing you're gonna tell
me that my data is safe with you and
this is in an era when Sony loses 90
million customer accounts and the NSA
has full cryptographic access to
Google's data centers I don't know I
somehow I can't get behind this cloud
data security so let me let me I'll do
an R so the first question is but why
would credit card companies care about
fraud why why did they chase that I
think they just let you take a ding on
their on on your credit report actually
turns out the law is written so that in
a fraudulent transaction you are
responsible for no more than $50 of the
charge and the bank keeps the balance
right there is a huge
incentive and credit cards to manage
fraud your debit cards another story
right actually I believe that the
incentives and the credit industry are
very much aligned with fraud detection
and we see that across all the major
credit card companies they are all
aggressively adopting and using new
techniques to chase fraud and that's
true broadly right I mean when it's a
cost to the business or when there's
reputational risk people want to get
better at it so we absolutely see that
happening and it's deep and real and
it's not it's not window dressing they
really care because it cost some real
money
the second question was so cloud data
management and cloud storage cloud era
why would I put my data in the cloud
when the NSA can steal it and when Sony
can't keep track of it and I'll say a
couple things so first of all once again
we just picked the name man you know we
don't actually store your data for you
we deliver a database system that
sometimes in data centers sometimes in
the public cloud but you do ask a newest
question as large-scale distributed
cloud computing becomes available and as
more and more data about all of us
becomes available how do I think about
security how do we think about managing
it a lot of companies freaked out about
the idea of putting their data in the
public cloud because they think then it
is at risk I'll tell you guys just
flat-out right now right here I bet you
Amazon is better at security than 99% of
the companies on the planet right so if
you're concerned about security you
should be much more concerned about your
own internal IT teams ability to detect
and prevent break-ins then you should be
about the big guys ability to do that
they are much better at doing that given
the scale at which they operate
but the proliferation of data and its
importance to the way we all work I mean
your medical data your credit data yeah
there are big questions there there are
important social important ethical
discussions for us to have about what's
okay to capture and what is okay to do
with that data I will tell you how
that this genies out of the bottle okay
big data has happened right it will not
happen that we decide all of a sudden
we're not going to do a metal Ektron ik
medical records right ship is sail
that's gonna happen the next question is
how do we secure how do we hold
responsible parties involved in their
dissemination right what is it okay to
deduce from that data and what is it not
okay to do certain that date if I'm an
insurance company should I be able to
look at your DNA data if I may thereby
be able to surmise that you've got a
disease that might increase the risk of
mortality right as a society we need to
have those discussions but that data
will be collected and is useful for
important meaningful well I believe
we're going to be better as a society
with the ability to capture a process
that data we need to be sensible about
what we do with it right and we really
as a society we haven't had that
discussion yet so in the past five years
but there has become like the fact that
distribution
bunch of other different ones that are
coming out Hortonworks map are what
would have to happen
very like who would have to come into
the market for you guys to be really
shaking in your boots so the question is
cloud era started first clutters the
number one had do company in the world
there are emerging competitors map are
and Hortonworks were specific ones cited
what would it take for cloud era what
would have to happen in the market who
would have to ant enter the market in
order to really freak us out and really
make us quake in our boots look there's
a big collection of established
enterprise IT players in the market
right now and they have very deep
pockets and the ability to plan on very
long time frames and I won't say we're
terrified of those folks but we are
deeply respectful and attentive to the
landscape in which we play right now and
look I mean another hint if you're going
to go start a company
if you're not constantly kind of gaming
out okay a big company a acquired small
company B what would that mean to us or
if small company be a small company C
formed an alliance or if a disrupter you
know entered over it you need to be
thinking about that all the time
I think we've got a reasonably well
articulated strategy that lets us not be
reactive be proactive but wall off
threats where we see them coming up so
you know what would it take to have me
quakin in my boots if I could answer
that question you should really find
another guy to run the company if we
knew the if we knew of something that
was that big an existential threat we
would address it proactively right
Hadoop came from nowhere to threaten a
bunch of existing players in the market
could that happen to us you know I pay a
lot of attention to what's going on in
innovation in data management right now
given where we are we work very hard to
embrace that innovation where it happens
is it possible that we could be
disrupted in that way you know the any
given year probability that's pretty
small over 30 years it's a virtual
certainty I don't spend a lot of time
worrying about a out-of-left-field never
could have predicted it two guys in a
garage made a new thing happen we pay a
lot more attention to what are the big
vendors doing what are their strategic
interests what are the emerging players
doing and what alliances their might
disrupt us and how should we position
ourselves to be best able to deal with
whatever happens in the market when
creating cloud era and and in the other
companies you started what what do you
think is the important thing that you
look for and the people you surround
yourself with that allowed you to really
push one another for it and so work so
successfully so the question is over the
course of my career and a lot of
different companies what has been the
most important trait in the people that
I've surrounded myself with and in order
to build success let me say just for the
record
Britain leave that one just kind of
petered out wasn't crashing failure
wasn't great olestra was a tremendous
success until the acquiring company
restated earnings three times in two
quarters that sucked a little bit my
next one year Mulligan I won't even name
but boy we flew that one into the ground
at very high speed sleeping I was
tremendous outcome and then cloud era
books not over yet but so far looking
pretty good
I'll talk both about sleeping yet but
even more about cloud era the quality of
the people in the organization that's
really all that matters right in my view
everything that we can claim as a
success ties to the fact that we have
recruited the world's best team right
and say that right out loud in front of
everybody I think we've been
fantastically successful in recruiting a
world-class organization including just
lights out fantastic developers we have
a very deep and careful process for
sourcing and filling sourcing candidates
and filling positions and we interview
not just for skills we interview for
capacity to learn because you know the
markets changing and we've got to get
better as time goes by I'm also really
when we're hiring people in the company
I'm looking for people with multiple
diverse interests right not just I am a
fantastic C++ coder but I am a fantastic
C++ coder who's summited five of the
nine highest peaks on the planet right
someone who does that has a suppleness
of mind that you want they chase tough
challenges and you could rely on them to
be interesting one reason I do that is I
spent a lot of time on the road and I
travel with a bunch of business
colleagues and you know after five days
of 10 hours of customer meetings on
Friday evening when you're sitting down
over a beer after that week you want to
talk about something and by god it's not
work right so there's the summited five
bounds guys that guys you you could talk
to that person right anyway we look for
diversity and intelligence and
flexibility and the people that we hire
and I will say I think we've been pretty
successful it's it's what makes cloud
era such an exciting place
and if you're good at hiring that way
early it's easy to keep it up if you
don't do that early it's impossible to
change it the reason is really great
people gravitationally attract really
great people right who wants to go join
a B team and be like the a person right
yeah you know I got better things to do
right but you walk in you think you were
the smartest kid in the class actually
you guys had this experience coming to
Stanford wherever you went to high
school you were the geniuses right you
show up here you're not even the
smartest person in your row right that's
a good place to be right that's that's a
good place to be Salesforce when you see
the landscape in five years and then
it's different than ten years so the
question is if I look at Cloudera si P
Oracle IBM IBM and Salesforce where do I
see what do I see happening so let me
say a number of those companies are very
good partners of ours and I'm not gonna
prognosticate on that I've certainly got
a view but I'm not going to
prognosticate on it I think the
relationships we have in the market and
the opportunity for everybody is big
we're certainly focused on growing our
share and growing the market I will
observe however that in that population
Salesforce has of late been a breakout
dramatic success and the reason is not
that it's been wildly profitable right
and in fact it's never been profitable
right that's business that successfully
lost money like forever right but it is
driving unbelievable growth on a
recurring revenue stream that is to
public market investors and think about
long-term value of the company a very
large installed base that keeps coming
back that is a tremendous place to be
when we think about this opportunity
what I'd love to do is grow as fast as
faster than the market that sort of
growth the sales force has proven other
companies have done likewise plunk
they have proven that you can live that
way you can fund that growth you can
deliver huge rewards to your
shareholders in that way of course all
these businesses one day need to pay
their bills the old-fashioned way with
profits right so no question you need to
get there but as markets are exploding
thinking incrementally is a waste of
time we're down to just about two three
minutes left and we're told we have to
stop sharp on the hour so maybe just one
more so open source projects
what are ones that you see that are up
and coming that look appealing or tell
us about getting your first one or two
customers
so what other open source projects do I
think are icing yeah well we pay a lot
of attention to stuff that bears on a
dupe right now a couple of projects that
were deeply interested in OpenStack for
elasticity and sort of cloud deployment
of this infrastructure we think private
clouds going to be huge and an open
source got a ton over socks got a ton of
momentum we just announced a
relationship with a Berkeley spin-out
called data bricks and they're
commercializing a project that was born
at UC Berkeley called spark for high
performance in memory analytics of data
you can imagine data analysis is really
sort of in our wheelhouse so those are a
few that we're paying attention to
there's a ton going on the open source
ecosystem one of the best things about
my job is I get to walk around and look
at all of it but those are two in
particular that we're paying attention
to and then you asked as the second part
of your last question I will note some
quick stories about winning early
customers early on our investors Excel
in particular helped with great
introductions we met through them big
bank who was super interested in this
new platform for data analysis and I'm
going to tell this anecdote without
identifying the bank for reasons that
will become obvious at the end so they
really loved what we were doing they
really wanted to use this new capability
but hey security data privacy
have a team called information risk
management that looks at vendors and
their products and decides whether or
not it's okay to use them and they've
got a book you got to fill in in order
to qualify key toss to win in this space
right so we want to take that deal down
and we met with information risk
management at this Bank like six times
we had the same meeting six times in a
row right it was just like we not make
it progress after six times I'm like
they're like guys timeout what's
happening here why are we done the risk
management got reels back in this here
well mark you know we put the know in
innovation yeah okay I guess we know
where we are then yeah living in big
company is tough and you got to do it
we're at the end thank you much
you